look man I don't know why you call me
thing better okay play me but hey I want
people to know people you're buying a
lot of [ __ ] for never paying his bets
ever try and pay me I paid him three
thousand dollars three [ __ ] grand i
uz what's up dog I'm gonna send you half
is a listen let your P's and Q's no no I
my issue with that fight Darko was not
easy it's with y'all here's what here's
what I have a question I have a question
for you rinses on it today like that
what uh three Vince oh I like Vince iPad
on that back don't worry low-cut socks
not a big deal kind of work gotta work
on my shoes look good though not bad
right um I have a I have a question a
fight question explained to me Yoel I
like he plays possum that overhand left
was crazy yes yes yes
props to Izzy first absorbing that okay
sure as he goes oh that guy can explode
like crazy that's not snap it out peanut
butter uh-huh
now I I have a question number one you
you don't do anything for the first two
rounds you go back to your corner corner
says done nothing to you from what I
could tell your corner says nothing now
I love where you going now wait then I
have another question I watched the guy
wrestle I watched that he's a two-time
world champion he beat Cael Sanderson
twice he is he is better is better
wrestler and there you can say grappler
as a good of grappler Habib or anybody
if everybody blame or daiquiri we know
that he can put is he on his back at
will and I will go a step further we
know he can keep is he on his back you'd
go peanut butter why in the world when
he when he closes distance like he did
when he gets is he down does he let him
up as opposed to just go from transition
to transition the transition until he
gets is he on the ground about chain
wrestling now I'm talking about chain
wrestling why again welcome you're in
the chain he's and again once again you
can't keep him from keeping you down or
keeping you keeping you on your back
because he goes from transition to
transition because the best in the world
at it because two times in a row and the
best grappler obviously issue so so I
don't understand why he wouldn't use
his wrestling and wise coaches aren't
yelling at him constantly use your
wrestling used your wrestling and and
take a page out of khabees book compete
was in the front row he couldn't look
the cup even said hey should I do what
you do cool I got you
correct why why didn't he do that and
get the belt because it cuz I do respect
or something elseö thema he's 42 - 42
years old it's the last time shot he's
everything right why wouldn't you go for
broke after the first three rounds after
the first three when he went back to
corner his team should be like dude our
game plan to counter the counter striker
offseason working he's [ __ ] up your
leg we're down three yeah maybe two
either way we're down yeah go for broke
brother this aren't this our last shots
our last broke wrestle get them down go
for a knockout we got to ground our
shield cuz we will never be back here
also he's the champ you have to take the
belt what you know in the chat you have
to take it we know this so if is he
decide to do that which he wants him
he's the kind of striker so you know but
if you want to do a different game plan
he can do that because he's the champion
if you're it's a home-field advantage
for him so you all being an awakened you
gotta take that [ __ ] belt you're not
gonna take it by sitting there it's you
not earned that right no that's not
that's not that's not to give it but
also that's his corner who's ATT some
the best in the very best the best best
when you're going into fifth round and
you're down for definitely three if
you're on you ELLs not sure give them
that first round but definitely down
three for sure you're losing a fight
correct there's no chance you can win
the fight
nobody says let's go for broke in the
fifth now did you guys really think you
were winning you were beating the champ
at that point we're down at least three
yeah 100 sent you down three yeah what
the [ __ ] my only my only I wanna kiss
your stupid mouth my only game in hot
today I'm hot you're hot cuz I lost
$3,000 my thing is this my only thing is
maybe yo l-look this coach says don't
[ __ ] tell me to wrestle I don't want
to hear from you guys I'm gonna beat him
at his own game I'm gonna beat him I'll
fight that's fine all right let's say
you don't want a rest cuz you worry
about your cardio so
all right [ __ ] it to wrestle but then
engage
cuz you're down three
it's probably for the weirdest thing and
I would also say you something well
maybe he doesn't he doesn't have the
mindset of a champion he won world he
was the world champion here's the mind
of course it's just awkward five tiers
of mindset I think he's so worried about
gassing out knocked out and I think
there's something there's something deep
inside that he's worried about gasps
announcer there's a fear of 50 outside
as a wrestle although if you're if you
were basically come out of the womb with
an underhook and that's all you do yes
you really don't get that tired cuz
that's that's your background your body
that's what it knows her feels he you
know he's weird and where where is he
like a sweater you know what's weird
about him huh I'm sorry it's all right
you know what's weird about him is even
when he gets concussed his first
reaction is it to grapple it's tough
strike yeah which for a wrestlers very
long it's very straight in his blood
remember this is I believe his father
and his uncle we're both Olympic boxers
dude yeah we're gonna have a moment of
silence right now cuz you all Romero do
our twin work Mitch come - should we ask
him what you'll Romero's mindset sure
Marc Maron's gonna be all over that idea
Marc Maron probably never watched an MMA
fight it's like now that fight between
you on e and ginger the great une in Jin
jack and that amazing shred us will yang
Jane is that her name Wei Lee Kang Wei
Lee yeah but bully Lee will say waily
waily both of the both of the most
incredible human beings they are both so
[ __ ] incredible
I don't know what's going on with both
of them I don't know how that fight was
the craziest [ __ ] at Absalon who'd you
have won in that fight I have yo I don't
know what I'm a FEMINIST
oh good you sure heard the talk he gave
me coffee
number one I am a feminist get older
dude hey dude you have winning that
fight I had you on him I had you on a -
but they need to rematch that should
been a draw I could because depending
are there draws yeah yeah I can be yeah
they can be ten ten rounds they should
gave some to that should've been a draw
but no loser so it would have been
there's no losers but yeah but there's
no losers in that and also the draw
would have built up the the rematch I
had you on a winning but I was like okay
this is the one fight judge can't [ __ ]
up they can't pick wrong here both are
winners which ever way you go it's it's
your cup of tea do you like tea or
coffee bowls are gray
I'm biased towards you honest oh my I
was loved you like Chinese people no I
love the Chinese people I'm not really
sound like you what's our Willie Chang
Chang Chang no I'm not worried about the
Chinese government but then again that's
okay it's not their fault but I really
admire that woman did you see the one
gentleman from Dagestan or cachaca Stan
who was like women should be fighting
after the fight oh he said that good
well you keep that you keep up that
awesome belief my friend see how far
that gets you in life well and your
country by the way wolf yeah phenomenal
fighters but also but that's his
perspective Toby yeah like that's the
way he was raised you know any better
well and I would say that GSB said the
same thing yeah but we're growing up all
of us we're all growing up you think
over there they like this are changing
our minds and they're changing minds
over there believe it or not the way you
change minds is not necessarily by
writing by Pilar's something it's by
doing and those women are getting in and
they changed my mind
hey they change I had some of that in me
I'm not saying all of it but but I had a
lot of eyes I still have it in me if
it's a really really pretty girl like
page or Tatiana or rich most of it and
they're like extremely hot and they get
punched in the face I feel different
yes if it's a dragon game punch in the
face I just do yeah I didn't grow up in
that I didn't grow up in that app if
that's what I mean and I'm not against
it by any means I love women find a good
foot into that fight women fight men
fight that's one of the best fights I've
ever seen is that what botifarra I'm
just not used to but that's what I mean
so I am I understand why he has a
culture that is very patriarchal and and
it's frankly very chauvinistic
it's also why and I have to say this
whenever you see cultures like that you
won't see a lot of innovation coming out
of those cultures you you'll see one
kind of strength they define strength as
the guy with the biggest muscles in the
biggest club you see one that shut their
God yeah you don't see a whole lot of
you don't buy a lot of products from
Dagestan you don't you just don't see a
lot of artistic innovation community
home-cooked meals in the span house yeah
keep what you do QC order you see order
there's a lot of emphasis on order on
the steel good time on hierarchy all
good it's you won't see a lot of do
Apple is not coming out of country is
not coming out of the country also not
spoke not a lot of not not a lot of
freaks come out there
I can see a lot of open-minded sexual
that is that's or or documents or the
it's under the old could since
Afghanistan now there's a whole lot of
satellite dishes now one thing you'll
notice if you talk to some of the CIA or
the
notes there's a lot there's a whole no
there's just a whole bunch of porn
watched in those households but under
yeah yeah yeah so you know there's
there's that there's there Alex I'll
drag that guy's feet through the [ __ ]
coal because the threes right no notion
well III think he should you still have
to you have to still have to say you got
to start you got a you're worthy of
criticism my friend and here's why we
don't tweet it out yeah like you know
could be feels exact same way but he's
on your tweet it now could be yeah
and I don't if you feel that way that's
how about if issue with it at all if
that's your prerogative not your
perspective that's what you were born
that's cool man I think should open your
eyes but if your dad and your trainers
and your entire culture in your
societies that way well you're gonna be
that I understand why he's that way I'd
be doing which is which is actually a
form of ignorance I think it's also then
upon him to maybe open his eyes and to
grow like all my bases don't tweet it
out yeah you can feel however you want
but don't don't you don't need announce
to the war if you want to tweet it out
just be ready for a fuckload of backlash
are you think he cares no but he might
care index n he doesn't corporate
sponsors of the UFC go we don't want to
go like this fighting and that can
happen unfortunately or fortunately it's
not ever known ever in the UFC never
really you don't think so yeah I do and
I guarantee you that doesn't happen
really I just could be feels the same
way and I trust me if harley-davidson
when I went hey we don't like the way
[ __ ] khabib spoke of women this way
can you not find on this card Dana would
say suck my dick sure sure which I by
the way I don't think anybody should be
censored for their point of view I just
think you should be ready for the
backlash that's me too if your entry
I'll just get ready but I don't think he
gives a flying [ __ ] yeah here's you see
a young man who's ignorant and has been
has been has been very useless yeah yeah
but [ __ ] I mean how do you argue how do
you say that by the way here's the other
question it's doubly ignorant when you
to fight that incredible how do you say
that when you watch those two on that
level of sky it's a weird time to do it
like do it do it today I don't do it the
night when the fight guy after watching
a fight were you watching the fight how
do you argue about down this forehead oh
my god
insane right what's her forehead looked
like now now well use it now thinking
meet you back here's what you can do is
compress the swelling I'm wearing a
bandana or a thing I've never seen
anything like it
clothes thing was ha making canada vs
jose oh and she had her nose smack and
those that smash you know what she looks
like she looks like the alien off family
god yeah
that poor thing and now she's got her
basically uh that's our thoughts black
yeah she's right they wrapped the
compress it that's long ago I remember
my cheek bud yes I do bring that [ __ ] up
choice how long do that bad take two
anyway after like two or three days so I
got a period and that's growing on my
cheek
oh yeah that's so well is there another
ankle right there that's it right there
I am not pressing my tongue against my
cheek there check out the tits
you got some tits on you you got some
tits handsome kid though yeah that's a
great shot
let me see that shot I would put that
one that worried says Brenda shot meets
Ben Rothwell that's a handsome look for
real that right there I'm serious well
that was a cloudy it does that was after
a crow cup no is that there Ben Rothwell
I think no my face wasn't marked up
that's a great I'm sorry but that's a
great bet says Brendan meats been wrong
that's a great picture before that's a
great we didn't do in Montreal either
you won that fight after that with a
broken nose but that's a great picture
that that should be framed what were you
doing it I don't know I just love that
picture that's that's like that's like
just giving everything you gave
everything you had right there
shaved head all [ __ ] up because you
I'm trying that you know that that but
like that looks like that was after I
beat Gabriel Gonzaga look at your face
god damn it sexy bastard oh no we're
just getting [ __ ] punched and just
get cut off oh I don't know why keep
looking at this not great
yeah just like dick dude I like that
picture ah hey your ear was a little bit
normal
nope that's that's that's this one
same [ __ ] Oh your friend dude yeah right
now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]